when Pixar began developing the third
Cars movie they decided to return to the
roots of the franchise with a story
centered firmly around Lightning McQueen
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to explain
all the deleted scenes original stories
and alternate endings that Pixar
developed for cars three during five
years of production but it didn't make
it into the final movie also I'm running
my cast three giveaway for two the art
of cars three hardback books on this
video if you'd like a chance to win one
of these two very cool books which
feature gorgeous concept art and
storyboards from cars three be sure to
subscribe leave a comment about the film
and also answer the question I'll be
asking later in the video quick warning
I will be discussing spoilers in this
video so take care if you haven't seen
the movie yet after director John
Lasseter made the first Cars movie he
was really keen for legendary actor Paul
Newman to return as the voice of Doc
Hudson for the sequel sadly though
Newman passed away in 2008 and while
Cars 2 does make brief mention of doc
details of how doc died were never
revealed in that movie however in an
interview with screen crush cars
creative director Jay Ward explained
that he had hoped to remedy the lack of
details about Doc's passing in cars 3 in
fact in an early version of the movie
there was going to be a flashback that
would have revealed how dog died Ward
described the deleted scene as a really
tender moment where McQueen is driving
and Doc's following him and it's like
the day your mentor passes away
although Pixar loves to make us cry the
scene was cut because as Ward himself
said it was just depressing I still
think this could have been an
interesting scene to include though as
although many cars and Pixar fans
enjoyed cars 3 many still want to know
what really happened to doc and his
Pixar proved in their incredible
introductory montage of Carl and Allie
and earth a character's death can
provide a deeper emotional connection to
a movie and its story one of the best
moments in the new movie is when
lightning crews and Matt go incognito at
the Thunder Hollow demolition derby
lightning covers himself in mud and
takes on the name of Chester Whipple
filter Cruz uses the alias Francis
beltline and Mac worse a Jocko flaco
disguise which if you've watched my
car's three Easter eggs
you'll know as a sneaky easter egg to a
real-life NASCAR monkey racer but the
theme of team 95 operating and training
undercover was originally going to be a
much more extended and long-running joke
throughout the movie
for example initially the Beach training
scene was going to be set up as a
pretend movie shoot where Guido was an
Italian film director and lightning was
an actor pretending to be Lightning
McQueen a bunch of other gags about the
team travelling around in disguise were
also cut from the final film
for example Mac was going to conceal his
identity in various ways ranging from a
traveling circus to a shipping container
and from a military vehicle to a
lumberjack the character of Cruz Ramirez
was very different in early drafts of
the story and initially she was actually
a male car but the filmmakers decided to
make her female car so she was more of
an outsider in the typically
male-dominated world of motor racing
originally Cruz was also going to be a
young rookie racer rather than a trainer
and an early idea was that when
Lightning met her at the Rusties
training center he would see her as a
younger version of himself in a very
similar way to have Doc viewed lightning
when he first met him in the first movie
in the end though the filmmakers felt
this was retreading too much of the
story from cars 1 so they began to make
her more of an opposite character to
lightning for example in the way she
lacked confidence ultimately the movie's
creators believed these changes to
Cruise's character helped build a more
interesting story by developing a more
Odd Couple style of relationship between
lightning and his new trainer the
relationship between Lightning and Cruz
culminates in the Florida 500 piston cup
event were midway through the race
Lightning realizes that Cruz is the
answer to beating Jackson storm so he
calls her back for his pit stop but
instead of going back out himself he
gives her his number 95 and tells her to
race in his place before settling on
this final twist though the filmmakers
considered a whole bunch of alternate
endings in one of those alternatives
lightning never took part in the final
race at all and entered Cruz into the
race instead presenting her as a new 95
to his friends from Radiator Springs
before the event this ending didn't work
well though because the filmmakers found
that there was a sense that the movie
was already finished at the point that
lightning
sited to stop racing which meant that
the remaining story felt underwhelming
in another ending McQueen ran the whole
race himself when it and then he decided
to mentor Cruz only at the very end of
the movie
however this ending made the film feel
hollow according to director Bryan
feed-in yes another version they both
took part in the race and had to compete
against each other but that didn't work
either because it split the audience
over who to support in the end the
filmmakers decided that to get the right
level of tension in the movies final act
they would have lightning pass on his
number mid race to Cruz but even then
there were still further variations
considered within this scene for example
at one point this passing of the torch
to Cruz was going to be more fraught
with McQueen getting angry at her when
she didn't understand what was going on
though finally they both would have come
to a proper understanding and
appreciation of each other I'm not sure
quite how I feel about the way the
number 95 was passed to Cruz in the
final film as although smokey explained
that the rules only say the number has
to be out there doesn't say who has to
wear it the confusion is initially
created meant this transition wasn't
quite as smooth as I would have liked
the car three filmmakers obviously spent
a lot of time considering all possible
options but I still wonder whether there
was another way to have done this it
didn't raise quite so many questions in
my mind while I was watching the movie
what did you think about the ending did
you enjoy it
or would you prefer to see something
different by the way there are some
interesting storyboards which hinted a
deleted scene or another alternate
ending where McQueen reveals his
transformation into the fabulous
Lightning McQueen at the Piston Cup race
rather than at the very end of the movie
you can see him emerging with Doc's
colors in the number 51 to a group of
press then the crowd and finally onto
the track where he faces up to Jackson's
storm in the final movie the reveal of
the fabulous Lightning McQueen is a much
more private moment for lightning with
his friends at Radiator Springs
although the movies final scene of
lightning and veining his own marsh to
doc Hudson was lovely these storyboards
hint that the filmmakers considered a
much more dramatic and symbolic way of
bringing doc back to life through his
protege to quote story supervisor Scott
Morse my having lightning announces new
number and colors at the
and cup I'm not sure this would have fit
the way the rest of the ending played
out for perhaps fans of Doc Hudson
especially would have enjoyed seeing
this scene production on car three began
at Pixar in 2013 but it wasn't until
2015 the final direction of the story
was decided on after John Lasseter was
inspired by the retirement of his friend
professional NASCAR racer Jeff Gordon at
the age of 43 which means that during
those two years various fascinating
ideas and stories were considered for
the sequel some of those early ideas
involved returning to route 66 and also
including route 99 and even racing on
dry bed lakes one idea that was
developed in a little more detail was an
exploration of Southern California car
culture plus celebrity culture in LA in
an interview with screen junkies news
director Bryan fee revealed that in one
early story lightning went to a
Hollywood Hills party and it was full of
actors and they had the old Batmobile
and the new Batmobile talking to each
other at the party obviously this was a
hole at the story but so imagine this
scene could have been a lot of fun as we
already saw car versions of Pixar movie
characters from Toy Story monsters
University in a bug's life in the
credits for the first Cars movie and I
imagine there could have been a lot of
potential for jokes and voiced cameos by
previous Batman actors or sound-alikes
I also wonder whether an la-based story
might have explored Sally's past history
and the city if you recall back in the
first Cars movie we learned that Sally
was originally a hotshot lawyer in Los
Angeles and it could have been
interesting to see her backstory
explored so are there any deleted scenes
or stories you would love to have seen
in cars 3 and do you think there should
be a fourth cars movie and if so what
would you like to see happen for a
chance to win this awesome the art of
cars 3 hardback book be sure to
subscribe and leave a comments about the
movie and also answer the following
question what famous superhero car
almost appeared in cars 3 turn on your
notifications to get all my new videos
where I'll be announcing the winners of
the giveaway
plus let me know what deleted scenes
you'd like me to do in future videos and
if you enjoyed this hit that thumbs up
button and check out more of my movie
deleted scenes and Pixar videos right
here congratulations to these three
winners of my arrow flash and Supergirl
giveaways who are on the screen right
now if you're one of them send me a
message on youtube or via my team
which you can find on my about page
thanks for watching and see you next
time hippie guy movie lovers